today marks the opening of the very  first not making this up  drive-through marijuana dispensary in  Colorado yeah yeah now the news of this  drive-through dispensary in Colorado has  led to a bit of confusion for some  people take a look good morning  I got some weed Oh sir you are at a bank  a weed bank no a money bank  I thought all drive-throughs had weed  now no I they did open a drive-through  marijuana dispensary about three hours  drive from here but this is a money bank  oh but can I get some weed okay  Oh can I get a cheeseburger - oh sweet  and do you have like ketchup and straws  and salt and pepper sorry  [Music]  I get some weed  [Applause]  you